today's topic i've been watching a lot
of uk radio
all right they got some good stuff where
they do like political commentary and i
always like listening to some of the
calls
because i think the people who do the uk
media do
some of them do a great job of having
conversations with folks so this is one
i wanted to play for you guys
it's a caller who called into the radio
station called lbc so
i'm hearing all these things about
sports and the blm this year
but what i'm not hearing is people open
up the conversation
to say i used to be racist and i was
registered now i'm not honest
that would make a blooming good phone in
actually wouldn't it so
i personally used to be resistant
and now i'm not and
if i was to be penalized for that
anywhere my
way of going around business would be to
say
i used to be racist and this was the
journey i took and this is why i'm not
and here i am punish me or not
so tell me your story then i want to
stop it right there
i want to just take a second to
appreciate something somebody
mentioned something about themselves
that some folks might think is cancer
worthy some people i think it's worth
condemning
and the radio host instead didn't go to
do any of that he said
i'd like to hear more about what
happened i think just sometimes that
patience and understanding is
the the difference between growing and
not you dig what i'm saying
giving people a chance to make mistakes
to learn to speak about them and to have
a lengthy conversation about it
and i think that's why i appreciate even
just like his tone and response
so i grew up i mean i'm 26 and i grew up
in blackpool which is predominantly a
white town
and as a child what i saw on the media
was this constant refugee story stuff
911 all these stories and people around
me
were missed and i would hear these
sawyers
and it would be funny funny funny
business you know having a giggle
and as i've got older i find it
disgusting
because i've took a journey when i've
gone to university i've gone to college
i've gone through life
and you meet people from different
backgrounds and you start to learn
that quickly and can be turned on you
yourself
so for example i learned irish history
and that's a whole kind of worms on its
own right and when you when you start to
open open up these
the history of who you are where you've
come from
you quickly learn that prejudice comes
in many forms
and my ancestors would have been some of
them would have been
prejudiced and people
keep all this council culture stuff
people were quick to come out and say no
i'm not this
i'm not just i'm not hearing anybody
talk about the journey of why they're
not just anymore so he said a lot of
interesting things in there
he spoke about irish history and if you
aren't familiar with irish it's
definitely worth reading about
from the very little that i've read you
would know that they are a group of
people
who've been heavily discriminated
against based off of their ancestry
alone both in america
and great britain as well so you know
just knowing that white people depending
on where you were born completely
devastating
how they were treated in a lot of ways
but then he also said something so i
think was interesting which is how
being around folks from different
cultures being exposed
being educated helped him to undo some
of the bad
thought patterns that he had this crazy
how knowledge can help you realize
that you are because in my opinion i
think a lot of prejudice comes from
faulty thinking and that you engage in
these thought patterns that are pretty
basic
because it simplifies the world around
you it helps you aggregate information
to come out to a conclusion to best
preserve yourself i see
refugees on boats therefore the media
has been telling me it's a crisis
therefore
they are bad people and i need to get
rid of those people or stay away from
those people right
if you don't interact with people from
those backgrounds maybe they got your
supermarkets from
syria maybe the person that goes to
school with you
is from lebanon if you don't get a
chance to interact with these people and
realize that they come in much different
faces than what the media presents to
you
then you're only going to know them in
one way and that could lead you down
these bad paths
so it was great to hear how him going
through these experiences helped him
undo this stuff
what do you think it's just a fact you
said it all
that's a fact it's really that it's also
propaganda
there's propaganda that we don't even
know that we are
subjected to what we see in the media
where we are bombarded by the media and
stuff like that you know you might think
it's just a movie
but if it's all the movies all you see
is the same thing the black person
playing the bad guy and a black woman
always being
angry and always creaming and always
have attitude
sometimes that's how you're going to
perceive that thing without having if
you're not in contact with that and the
only contact that you have with black
people is a tv
or the con the only contact that you
have with a certain group is what you
have in tv or media
and the only perception that they give
you when they shoot at you
is a negative one sometimes that's going
to form your perception
it's not even so much your fault it's
what you see it's what you see was it's
what you're
you're you're basking in now what is
your fault is what you do with that
perception
that's your responsibility which you do
with those images and know
you know all those people i know those
people they're lazy who told you or
they're lazy
what would you mean they're lazy what
experience did you have with them that
they were lazy
i don't know that's what i know yeah
well now it's time to have a little you
know voyage and a little
trip to what you know yes
you got your responsibilities to
question everything
that's your responsibility so i
understand that everybody everybody got
their trauma
everybody got their experiences
everybody got their their their biases
but that's what responds to the question
that those
i used to have prejudice against blind
people of course you did
yeah because growing up i just thought
they were idiots and airheads
yeah that had easy lives because that's
what that was was shown there were old
jokes about it there was books written
just for blonde jokes yeah and i didn't
interact with blind people so i
carried that later on in my life so even
when i saw women if i i was like man
women with dark hair only
right and if a blonde wouldn't woman
even try to protect might get away from
me
right but that just came from my biases
yeah that just came from my biases and
the way i internalized i could easily
see how that applies to a lot of
different things today's video is
sponsored oh wait
all right you already know okay we're
ready today's video is sponsored by blue
chew say it with us now blue chip it's
time for you to gain more
confidence and longer lasting
experiences in the bedroom with
bluetooth tablets okay
you deserve better she deserves harder
get it together
bars listen blue chew is a unique online
service
that offers you the same active
ingredients
as a viagra in cialis but in a chewable
form
and at a fraction of the cost and one of
the best parts is that you know
bluetooth it's an
online service so you don't need to go
to the doctor and have an awkward
conversation with that person
all you gotta do is go to bluetooth.com
you just need to consult with one of
their medical licensed professionals
and once you're approved we just ship it
to your door and we got a special deal
just for you guys you can try bluetooth
for free when you use promo code abba
all right and all you gotta do is pay
for the five dollar shipping that's
bluechew.com using promo code abba and
get your first month
free so big shout out to bluetooth for
sponsoring this video what was there one
um sort of light bulb moment for you or
was it just a gradual thing
so so one thing that happened when i was
was a bunch of people from
manchester who come from i assume
caribbean origin
weren't very nice to me and i was i was
interested what was to say the only
white man
in in that group and all these racial
slurs were targeted at me
and then all the things that they were
joking about weren't too dissimilar to
what people from my background
were doing i mean i quickly learned you
know that
these what goes around comes around and
it's all about to me having people
experience people from different
backgrounds and
experience different things but you see
i think a lot of people
um aren't open to this dialogue because
they get defensive and they've got
careers to
to to you know i don't know what you do
oh you'd say you've got careers that
they want to maintain
so they will never openly say i used to
be racist
and here's why i'm not now i want to say
something about that so
when i was growing up at least in high
school when i immigrated to
canada at the time where i moved there
there was a lot of animosity between the
black teenagers and the white teenagers
okay it was like i'm not even talking
like oh i don't like you it's like
they used to beat each other up they
used to catch each other when they were
alone
and you'd get your ass stomped out and
this is not hyperbole i would watch it
every weekend
you know people would go across the
bridge to go beat up white folks and
they would come across
it was really weird time in some ways
and i remember i was um
i was just i was present with a group
people went to a club at one point
and um i knew one of them really well
but the rest of them i was just loosely
affiliated with
and after i came out the club i was uh
waiting for
a cab to head back and they started
huddling up
now what's going on next thing i know
they went they laced up some dude
right beat him up snuffed them out dude
was on the floor they took his shoes
took everything
and if you used to go clubbing you might
know this you can speak to zero bouncer
every time you went out there were
fights yes every time every time i went
out
people get knocked out fights pepper
spray stabbing
every weekend friday saturday sometimes
even sunday you know
we go to church then we lay somebody
they were always fighting so me i see
this i'm confused
and then people just spread out once
they beat somebody up everyone books it
and i remember just thinking back on
this recently but i'm like
i wonder if that white dude who got beat
up by those black people developed
negative emotions towards black folks
the same way a lot of the black folks i
knew who got beat up by white dudes
developed those feelings and there was a
lot of that tension and sometimes
that's an extreme example where like
violence but sometimes with even more
subtle situations
where you get insulted by a group or you
get these kind of it could jade you
right it creates that kind of animosity
is that fairs i just i'm not saying that
what i'm saying is i understand how this
cycle kind of functions and i've
witnessed it before
so those are my thoughts what did you
have to say about everything i mean
you you develop some kind of ptsd i know
i have ipgs the funny thing is
funny thing is that you already know
it's about to be no it's not it's not a
big thing it's really just funny thing
is
now it's like uh it's like a
fashion to have high boots you know
people wear black people wear you see
a couple of years back you saw chris
brown
where duck martin's high boots and i
have
you know i like shoes you know i have a
lot of shoes and stuff like that
never bought doc martens not because i
don't think they're nice but it's
because of what it represents
for me right i grew up in an era
where there was a lot of there was still
a lot of skinheads
and
the red dot martin's 21 holes
white laces
that was trouble i was i would go to the
bus
i take a bus and it was if at the end of
the bus
there was bummer jackets and there was
duck martin's
21 holes
white laces
i gotta get home but i gotta get through
this first you know
who was about to get it in it's not it's
just what i
and and all of this had to happen it's
not sometimes
if i would get off the bus stop it would
it would it would
things would have to happen a throw down
you know i mean
so the bummer jackets i'm fine because
the guys wearing the black bummer
jackets they were all right you've seen
me with the black bummer jackets
they were fine with us but a red bummer
jackets
the red duck mines as a matter of fact
you know my mentor
my mentor was telling me stories about
him in quebec city
fighting skinheads and having to rob
red bummer jackets because it was real
it was life that's what was happening
so yes it creates a certain ptsd
it creates something with you that stays
with you because of things that you
endure you know i mean
there's always that scene in american x
story
where the guy puts his math on this i've
seen that before the movie
real life you know i mean seeing stuff
like that happen
taking i'm not going to go into the
details but
so i can understand why some people are
going to have certain
if they live through the same era i
lived through
and for no reason they see someone
getting jumped like that
in a bus with machetes and stuff like
that or
whatever hating the other group was kind
of just part of what you did
you had to it was kind of like an
open-air prison
you had your group and you had to stay
with your group and if you were mingling
that's why sometimes i was
because on my street i was in a good
neighborhood and my friends were white
right so and that's why i
segregate my friends not all my group
friends chill
or have met right i have this group for
that
i have that other group for that and
they segregate because sometimes it will
not mean
they cannot meet because i had this
group of friends that were really into
hip-hop and they were black
and they were not or they were order or
the other group of friends that i had
that were really mixed but they were
from
the projects they couldn't mix with the
kids from my street
they could have kids they could have
mixed with the people for my like it
couldn't mix
and that mentality of segregating my
friends
because i had to coat switch throughout
a lot of things right
it stayed and it's there so i can go
really deep with that you have to
understand
why you're doing certain stuff and i
segregate my friends
certain friends are not going to meet
certain other friends my girlfriend
my girlfriend my girl my wife hasn't met
maybe
my wife has met only maybe not 10
percent of the people i know
10 of the people i know because they
don't mix
yeah you know what i mean it does it's
not i know it's not going to be a fit no
it's not going to mix it's not going to
go it's not
it's not her thing or it's not and i do
that with all my friends all that to say
i could see another group that say why
people witness things on that and
feeling some type of feeling some type
of way now like i said
we said before it is your it's my job
to know what to do with that and know
where it's from and do something about
that and i don't judge whatever
you buy doc martens do you boys for
fashion that's only me i'm not gonna
judge you on that necessarily
but i do have my ptsd's and the things i
went through
yeah let's go interesting in the
comments below leave us your thoughts
i'ma put my belt back home
[Music]